Alright, now we know how to use the
Mapreduce programming model to count words. That's great, but
counting words is pretty specific and it's not amazingly
interesting. Can we use the Mapreduce programming model to
do more interesting things? We sure can. let's
revisit the AADHAAR enrollment data from way back in
lesson two. Say we want to know how many enrollments
happened in each district. We can perform this calculation
using the map produced programming model. Of course,
we saw in lesson two, we could easily perform
such a computation with a SQL query. Or a
Python script. Using Mapreduce to solve this problem isn't
necessary with data our size. But imagine if
we had terabytes and terabytes of data. Say, line
items for the AADHAAR enrollment of every single Indian
citizen. We'd have no choice but to use Mapreduce.